in what's looking like one of the
biggest potential deals in the history
of cryptocurrency the exchange binance
run by Xiang Peng Zhao or CZ is planning
to buy out its rival FTX in a tweet by
CZ the CEO wrote quote FTX asked for our
help there's a significant liquidity
crunch to protect users we've signed a
non-binding letter of intent intending
to fully inquire ftx.com and help cover
the liquidity crunch end quote adding
that binance would be conducting a full
due diligence in the coming days Sam
bankman freed ftx's CEO admitted to the
company facing liquidity issues and that
FTX has come to an agreement on a
strategic transaction with binance to be
clear Finance has the ability to pull
out of the deal at any time according to
CZ ftt ftx's native token dropped 31 to
15.30 as concerns around bankman Freed's
businesses ripped the market FTX also
appears to have pause processing client
requests for withdrawals on November 6
CZ tweeted he would liquidate binance's
ftt Holdings quote due to recent
Revelations that have come to light CZ
did not specify the nature of the
revelations but they appear to be
related to the withdrawal request
backlog at FTX and allegations of the
weakness of ftx's balance sheet Forbes
estimates show FTX ants affiliate ftx.us
have seen their revenue Fall by 52
percent and 57 percent respectively in
the 12 months through October a less
severe decline than the overall Market
61 binance was among ftx's early
investors but gave up its stake in the
company before ftx's record fundraising
last year FTX had raised one billion
dollars from SoftBank temasek and other
investors at a valuation of 18 billion
dollars in October the company raised an
additional 420 million dollars from 69
investors putting the valuation up to 20
25 billion dollars
[Music]